a lie they keep telling the media oh
it's Hamas that wants to kill all the
civilians they want to kill all Jews
from the river of the sea they want to
kill everybody but Israel cares about
you know they do all this research and
they make sure they everything is
precise and all their intelligence is
precise and they just want to kill the
supposed terrorists this is all a lie
they're killing their own hostages and
they're using the dumb bombs from the
1950s seriously this is the stuff and I
brought this up on talk TV that we've
got to expose to the people because the
propaganda is so strong from the Israeli
government they're trying to convince
everybody that they're so concerned with
Palestinian civilian life and they don't
want to kill anybody they're killing
their own hostages and they're bombing
indiscriminately and we are calling for
it to be stopped